[Music]
[Applause]
live from the nestle arena welcome to
the finals of the 1987 jazz fit
championships
representing the body shop from
hollywood california
flash
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and from the skin shop from detroit
michigan lightning
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
good
[Applause]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we met b-boy joseph in atlanta ga hi
joseph what's up
stop the music
[Music]
has he started yeah i'm pretty sure this
is it
[Music]
thank you
yeah thank you yeah i ain't done yet
though thank you joseph it's it's
definitely a no for me it's a no i'm
sorry
no
all right
thank you joseph thank you
because you know i ain't got no formal
training no nothing like that i learned
on the streets
that was very impaired as it turns out
joseph
thank you for coming you know that my
mama's on drugs and my daddy in jail
it's not
not really relevant
born in a coffee can under a bridge
that's terrible joseph that's that's
awful but it's not going to my sister
shot my brother while my cousin beat my
uncle okay now
it's a little bit much joseph thank you
very much but put myself through school
by renting my body out as a heroin
suitcase all right i see what's going on
joseph please we do have other dancers
here today who are waiting their turn
very politely no joseph let her come on
stage let her come no joseph if i won
this competition i could put a roof over
my house cause i got a house ain't got
no roof for real though joseph just one
little thing though don't
do it joseph it was a loud bridge don't
finish that i got hearing damage in this
ear joseph and also in this area the
bridge have trucks go over it because
the bridge keep it 15 ton hold it
put it in your mouth
and get off my stage
rated six joe that's a big truck seth
okay joseph please and who is this oh
who is this right here this is my 12
year old daughter who i raise all by
myself without the help of anybody else
in the entire world she is my
inspiration joseph it doesn't matter
there's nothing you can do or say that's
going to make us change our minds today
that right there that right there that's
her daughter she blind
come on
[Applause]
so i raise them both by myself without
nobody else's help come get your ticket
to vegas
i am
[Applause]
[Music]
noise
[Applause]
[Music]
what you doing i'm just noising your
noise don't
[Music]
it's mostly about the dancers
oh yeah
besides
i'm kind of the guy that says noise
noise what happened nothing happened i
just noised you because of you standing
up yourself and you're placed in this
damn circle no no no noise okay noise is
my thing
no more noise from you
[Music]
noise
[Music]
noise noise
[Music]
noise
noise
noise
[Music]
noise
[Music]
noise
[Music]
noise
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
voice
[Music]
noise
[Music]
[Applause]
noise
[Music]
nice
[Music]
noise
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
race war
it's a goddamn
[Applause]
race flash mob flash mob cancel
the flash mob is canceled and now
we have a special treat hold on to your
yarmulkes okay
from east to west you know they're the
best getting you in the zone for your
milestone is that cute please welcome
gavelta fresh and dr dreidel
[Applause]
[Music]
when you see black people at a bar
mitzvah it's very exciting it's like a
scary ride and the kids just love it
right now we are the number one ball
slash bob mitch for party motivators in
all of nassau county i mean you got
the bot missiles
always to men you know all of them
coming through like a velda kaya
with the recycled dress and i mean the
hutzpah these guys
with their fakakta shtick it's it's a
real shonda on what it's supposed to be
simca yeah yeah supposed to be a sim
card
you just really can't put a price on the
look on your child's face when they see
a black person for the first time
oh it's just magical really
is he getting back up or what we are not
technically chosen we're chosen by the
chosen which is kind of better than
being just the chosen that's right it's
less responsibility jews are like black
people but we were black people before
there were black people
um well i guess that's not true they
were just in a different part of the
world they're all black people coming to
get me help
[Music]
i find it spiritually intoxicating
i find it culturally fascinating
and we find it monetarily exhilarating
when we say sarah you say schwartzman
sarah
i mean the fact that we're willing to
put forth the extra time is what sets us
apart i mean how often is a 13 year old
gonna hear their own name
we learn that name
we rehearse it
[Applause]
judaism
can be a very somber religion that's
right you know something we learned
along the way is that the word ghetto
means something very different to these
people
to tell you the truth i was a little
nervous about the whole thing and no not
because they were black but
because you never really know what those
kind of people are gonna do
[Music]
if we can have some fun some life some
color to a jewish person's life when
they're still young they might not grow
up and run away from black people when
they say maybe they won't
or uh
fire people so willy nilly
when they're older
we provide a service
to these people
we motivate parties
so that's what we do
that's what we do we motivate parties
[Music]
[Music]
it's friday night make some noise
[Music]
cause you're an actual pimp put your
hands up if you own a bunch of women put
your hands up
[Music]
if you're gonna hit it all night put
your hands up if
[Music]
without the benefit of viagra put your
hands up
[Music]
put your hands up if you treat her like
objects
[Music]
put your hands up if you kill other
people put your hands up
[Music]
if you the biggest boss here put your
hands up
[Music]
if you run an actual drug ring put your
hands up
[Music]
if you just realize that you're full of
[ __ ] put your hands up
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]